[Musique]
nous sommes le 16 février 2017 bonsoir
bienvenue pour cette nouvelle édition du
7 8 les invités émission dédiée à celles
et ceux qui font l'actualité dans le
département candidate debout la france
dans la 11e circonscription des yvelines
sylvia cantaluppi est aussi la
présidente d'honneur du mouvement dans
le département elle nous expliquera les
raisons de son engagement depuis de
nombreuses années aux côtés de nicolas
dupont aignan et puis à pau labo zone
est en charge des trophées de robotique
événement national qui propose à des
équipes de jeunes de créer un robot
filoguidé de véritables défis
scientifiques et techniques finale
régionale ce week end à saint quentin en
yvelines parmi la quarantaine d'équipés
engagées
sept sont issus de l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines bonsoir à
toutes les deux nous parlons donc
politique et puis innovation en quelque
sorte
ce soir on va parler politique tout
d'abord pour débuter cette édition un
nicolas dupont aignan le député de
l'essonne candidat à la présidentielle
estime que françois fillon en s'entêtant
met en danger la droite vous êtes
d'accord
oui tout à fait nicolas dupont aignan
donc et a toujours eu cette cette
position de ce 10 mai il après il avait
promis au début il voulait que les
candidats soient un des casiers
judiciaires vierges est propre et carrée
avant voit ce qui se passe parce que
quand on arrive comme ça au dernier
moment
bon c'est vrai que en plus et n'ont pas
de plan b donc ils n'aiment pas beaucoup
les plans b g les républicains donc ils
en ont pas même pour les sauver
eux-mêmes
donc effectivement il ya des gens qui
n'ont pas force qui sont déçus qu'ils
sont en colère et qui vous disent oui on
est déçu on est en colère on est ravi
mais on est obligé d'aller voter quand
même mais pour l'instant votre candidat
ne profite pas en fait de ces en ut
françois fillon les sondages ne donnent
pas d'impulsion dans le sens de la
candidature de les soldes âge
1 chez nous en plus ce sont des visions
au minimum par deux voire par trois
hauts pourcentages donc quand on
multiplie par deux ou trois c'est déjà
plus sympathique
et puis les dernières élections ont
montré que les sondages voilà c'est des
photographies donc pour vous il peut y
avoir des électeurs doit public 1 qui
vont se reporter sur la candidature de
l'environnement je pense que si les gens
réfléchissent et en fait tu penses à
nous parce que c'est vrai qu'on est
quand même un petit peu mis à l'écart on
parle jamais de nous on parle toujours
des mêmes cinq candidats
les jours où les électeurs comprendront
qu'il ya un autre candidat qui est prêt
qui se comportent autrement qu'à un
autre projet et qui peut répondre aussi
bien à ce qu'a pu proposer monsieur
fillon mais en n'étant pas dans les
extrêmes et dans les emportements
d'autres partis et bien voilà on est le
candidat républicain de gaulliste social
ce qui est quand même l'origine de
monsieur fillon qu'il a oublié pas nous
vous parliez de ses candidats candidate
d'autres partis politiques toujours sur
sur la droite mais plus à droite
peut-être dans l'échiquier la présidente
du front national justement marine le
pen qui a lancé récemment un signal à
tous les patriotes et elle a mentionné
en particulier henri guaino ou encore
nicolas dupont aignan oui bien sûr à
venir la rejoindre
en fait cet appel est un sos parce qu'en
fait bon
les données presque favori du premier
tour bon c'est bien le premier tome pour
arriver à la présidence de la république
faut aussi gagner le second tour ce qui
est moins facile pour elle tout cas elle
fait un appel aux patriotes mais c'est
pas envisageable un rapprochement entre
votre candidat et le front national
non nous nous sommes des gaullistes
sociaux
elle a quelques gaullistes chez elle
parce que voilà il ya des gens qui ont
si besoin de faire des carrières etc ont
besoin d'être plus de sous les feux de
la rampe
bon mais y'aura pas pas de rapprochement
même si effectivement on a sur certains
points on est parfaitement d'accord ben
oui forcément
mais il y a des problèmes de fond qui
sont qu'on n'arrive pas à tous mais
heureusement avec henri guaino alors
parce que henri guaino lui voudrait
partir en tant que candidat à la
présidentielle henri guaino qui n'a plus
l'investiture dans la troisième
circonscription qui est le député
sortant sur cette circonscription la des
yvelines la troisième henri guaino
nicolas dupont aignan par s'entendre si
si ça ce serait un vrai bonheur ils se
parlent régulièrement imaginaire henri
guaino candidat dans la troisième
circonscription des yvelines
mais sous l'étiquette dlf et non pas l
air on pourrait vous deviez cieux je
veux pas pour répondre à cette question
en tant que présidente d'honneur du
mouvement pour les yvelines je vais me
risquer tant pis je me fais rousse
piller oui j'aimerais vraiment beaucoup
ce que je connais bien monsieur guaino
on
était autour de même table et de même
tribune a beaucoup d'occasions
vous lui demanderez à lui il sera
bienvenu en plateau à beyrouth et oui
parce que vraiment c'est vraiment
quelqu'un qui parle autrement qu'à des
choses intéressantes à dire mais qui
semble s'engager sur un chemin personnel
ce qui pour un gaulliste est bizarre si
on part du programme maintenant
justement vous l'avez évoqué votre
candidat se définit comme gaulliste est
plus modérée que marine le pen le
programme dans les grandes lignes ces
indépendances nationales progrès social
c'est à dire c'est à dire de d2 ne pas
faire de l'économie une un objectif
d'économies n'est qu'un moyen pour l'ego
l'isr effectivement il faut faire
attention à ce qu'on fait réduire
éventuellement la dette mais l'idée
c'est de donner le bien-être les clips
du peuple et dans le peuple dans son
entier nous sommes des républicains donc
donné deux entre autres par exemple pour
l'école républicaine qu'on est une des
chances à tous les petits français de la
même façon puisque absolument pas le cas
maintenant voilà il ya eu donc c'est
vrai que nous par rapport à l'europe ont
là une position on aimerait arrêter de
subventionner nos concurrents au modèle
l'europe on en fait une europe des
nations libres indépendantes qui font
des projets ensemble une europe de
projets la plus belle réussite d europe
de projets c'est quand même ariane dont
tout le monde parle ça jamais telle
union européenne ariane c'était des
accords entre état libre et indépendant
qui on veut un projet commun l'europe ça
marche comme ça il faut réinstaurer un
certain protectionnisme
bien sûr ce que fait donald trump par
exemple j'allais vous dire faut pas
confondre protectionnisme et d'ériger
des murs de faire des choses un peu non
la protection c'est juste une protection
c'est pour un mur c'est pas une barrière
ouvrir des frontières des frontières
c'est comme la peau c'est à dire ça
permet des échanges c'est juste une
protection c'est pas une barrière
voilà une chose candidate dans la 11e
circonscription d
la présidentielle d'abord les
législatives derrière et vous serez
candidate comment va s'organiser cette
campagne sur le terrain
comme toujours nous on est sur le
terrain donc on va dans toutes les
villes les gares les marchés on compte
du temps pour parler avec les gens
parce que la candidature de nicolas
dupont aignan elle n'est pas si évidente
comme ça et pour les candidats aux
législatives c'est pareil ça qu'on a
besoin de s'expliquer parce que les gens
comprennent pas toujours là encore
malheureusement qui ne connaissent pas
bien la qui connaît ski swiss a pas
l'air trop mal mais qui situent pas bien
donc on prend du temps mais on est
nombreux militants on est sur le terrain
et on explique notre positionnement
ce qu'on veut ce qu'on veut pas elle est
ouverte cette 11e circonscription qui a
pour l'instant une inconnue de taille
puisque le candidat du parti socialiste
sortant c'est benoît hamon il est engagé
dans un autre combat pour l'instant donc
elle est ouverte sa circonscription elle
est ouverte
oui elle est ouverte s'est même des
courants d'air chez nous pour l'instant
donc voilà après est ce que fera
monsieur hamon après sa présidentielle
en fait il ya trois solutions dont six
mois il a gagné la question ne se posera
pas soit si la gagne pas ou y restera je
pense parlementaire mais dans quelle
chambre qu'elle change traduira-t-il
salarié absent des yvelines
louis il l'a dit sur cette antenne
d'ailleurs on verra par la suite
bah oui et on organisera bien évidemment
un débat avec tous les candidats et vous
aurez peut-être l'occasion d'échanger du
coup avec lui vous restez en plateau on
va continuer cette édition du 7 8 les
invités on va parler d'une opération qui
est menée depuis maintenant 18 ans c'est
18 ans par l'association planète
sciences ile de france la rencontre
régionale des trophées de robotique ce
pour les jeunes de 7 à 18 ans ils
viennent de divers horizons et ils
travaillent en équipes ils réalisent des
robots des robot filoguidé ils sont des
créations originales
la finale régionale c'est ce week end à
montigny le bretonneux à la ferme du
manet ce sont des jeunes qui vont
travailler en équipe ils vont construire
eux mêmes les robots il ya une vraie
plus value et il ya un vrai projet
éducatif sur cette opération tout à fait
l'idée ses côtés qui part de rien donc
dans votre reportage tout à l'heure la
petite fille elle expliqué complètement
partie de quelques fils électriques
d'une base son carton en bois avec les
éléments qu'on souhaite et ont créé ce
qu'on veut à partir d'un règlement donc
le règlement qui change chaque année il
indiquer comment faire
dans quel cadre qu'un cahier des charges
vont s'inscrire mais libre imagination
et innovation pour les jeunes en général
c'était bon et plutôt bien ces jeunes
ils ont de l'imagination
tout à fait c'est incroyable quand il ya
des contraintes ils vont trouver la
solution de pour nous pour y répondre
et ça dépend vraiment de leur
imagination et en plus en équipe ils
vont avoir des idées très différentes
les uns des autres on voit des images
des éditions précédentes alors c'est une
compétition c'est un concours il ya des
épreuves
comment ça fonctionne des robots
s'affrontent par équipe où il ya des
épreuves individuelles aussi non les
rôles ils se confrontent par deux donc
deux par deux on a trois phases de
qualifications donc le matin et en début
d'après-midi sur ces phases de
qualifications donc les robots ils vont
aller se rencontrer sur des matches de
90 secondes et au bout de trois matches
de 90 secondes les meilleurs ceux qui
ont fait le plus de points parce que du
coup il ya un nombre de points qui est
compté ils vont passer en huitièmes
quarts demi-finales et finales federer à
samedi s'est ouvert au public à la forme
du manet s'ils souhaitent assister à
cette compétition et puis on y reviendra
bien sûr dans notre journal de de lundi
il ya une quarantaine d' équipes qui
vont participer il y en a sept de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines tout à fait le
niveau de cette année il avait vu un
petit peu ces mails alors j'ai vu celle
de saint quentin en yvelines j'ai la
chance parce qu'en fait cette année on a
on a un projet sur saint quentin c'est
l'idée c'est de pouvoir tester aussi
leurs robots de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines donc à une
table de tests qui étaient réalisés par
le skylab qui installé au pôle sciences
de la ferme du manet et du coup se sait
ces robots de devil de montigny
d'attraper et de la verrière ont pu
tester le robot donc j'ai pu aller voir
ce que ça donnait et des niveaux donc on
espère qu on aura des bons matchs demain
alors non on n'a pas de favori mais on
aime tous les robots il ya des robots
qui viennent d'un peu partout mais c'est
vrai que bon on espère que qu'il y aura
voilà des beaux matches il ya des
catégories d'âge aussi non parce qu'ils
ont entre 7 et 18 ans j'imagine que
les plus jeunes de septembre rencontrent
pas leur céder alors si ça peut arriver
surtout les premiers matches après ça
serait partie en fonction des niveaux
mais ça peut arriver qu'il y ait des
tout petits qui se retrouvent avec des
lycées ce qui est encore plus
d'émulation j'imagine oui la gestation à
presque 20 ans maintenant chaque année
vous essayer de renouveler mettre un
petit peu de nouveautés vous avez parlé
de ce partenariat avec le skylab
notamment oui
alors ça c'est au niveau local
effectivement on a ce partenariat avec
le skylab le département des yvelines et
et la préfecture on a aussi au niveau
national donc parce que comme vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure c'est une
compétition qui au niveau national voire
international le règlement change d'une
année sur l'autre et les les actions
changent d'une année sur l'autre
donc l'année dernière ce que vous avez
montré à l'instance était sur le thème
de la plage cette année c'est sur le
thème de la lune
donc mon village donc c'est un projet
justement de d'arianespace justement sur
sur ce sujet là et on voit encore une
fois elle c'est l'une des équipes qui se
prépare c'est une équipe de deux trappes
seulement que vous avez découvert si
vous étiez avec nous au début de cette
soirée pendant le journal tout à l'heure
il ya des démonstrations aux marges
aussi de cette compétition il ya
d'autres petits rendez-vous justement
pour le public tout à fait donc le
public pourra venir sur toute la journée
à partir de 10h30 donc appart à part les
matches il y aura aussi des animations
donc la pollution sera des animations
sur la biodiversité des sols donc on
fera pas que de la robotique
après le skylab sera là aussi avec des
démonstrations donc d'imprimantes 3d de
différentes actions plutôt technologique
et d'innovation
on a aussi une association micro nets 91
nous on planète sciences ile-de-france
ont fait des animations aussi sur en
perd donc il ya une rue ampère à
montigny donc on en profitera pour
parler d'un père et il y à aussi elles
deux associations de l'estacade et
associations étudiantes tout à fait
qu'ils seront présentes pégase et une
dernière question rapidement juste les
les jeunes et leurs parents peut-être
qu'ils découvrent cette opération ce
soir s'ils veulent participer les autres
années c'est possible on peut inscrire
son école sa classe a fait son école sa
classe son groupe d'amis
son association sont centraux culturel
son club de loisirs ça ressemble il
faudra vous rendre samedi à la ferme du
manet dès le matin 10h30 ce sera ce
trophées de robotique pour participer en
équipe merci d'être venu nous en parler
merci aussi cl vient quant à lui d'être
venu évoquer la campagne de nicolas
dupont aignan est également les quelques
lignes de programme on aura l'occasion
d'y revenir et notamment avec votre
candidature dans la 10e circonscription
des yvelines merci à toutes les deux la
très belle soirée sur notre antenne
[Musique]